yeah well it wasn't any of these all
right last piece of Doctor Who news the
stuff that came out and was revealed at
San Diego comic-con that I'm going to
talk about the new sonic screwdriver
which my guess is also now available so
gonna be crossing my fingers for giving
that for Christmas I have traditionally
for the past I'm not even sure five six
years I've usually gotten us on a
screwdriver for Christmas and my 11th
doctor one needs a replacement but other
than that I think I was kind of had all
of them but now I've got to know what I
can get so the sonic screwdriver I have
not looked into the specifics of what
people have said about it or what
people's impressions are about it I got
enough of a sense that it seems like
people are kind of divided on it but I
like it like flat-out straight-up I like
it I think it looks cool and and there's
a couple of specific reasons I like the
more organic look to it and this was I
skipped over this when I did my talked
about the panel there was a little bit
of discussion where chip Nall said that
there was a story behind how the doctor
comes but but by this particular
screwdriver and actually that's kind of
interesting because we haven't dealt
with the doctor getting these I
definitely not knew who I don't think
it's ever really addressed in classic
who either he just kind of has them you
know the the Ninth Doctor just had it
the Tenth Doctor just had it the
eleventh Doctor a new one just popped
out of the TARDIS one time you know it
seemed like the it was the same with
with twelve although I and I know this
is controversial
I liked him better with the sonic
sunglasses but that we're going to
explore a little bit more about what is
involved in actually crafting one of
these things because I think actually
today the only person who we've seen
make one was Amy in the girl who way
so that's a little odd oh well yeah we
didn't actively see it but you know you
know what I'm saying there I think do I
make sense do I ever make sense to
anybody
I'm getting all existential here okay
moving on so I like the idea that it
looks like it was something that was put
together a little bit more on the fly
and so I'll be really interested in
knowing the back serve bus behind that
and more to the point I like that it
looks not only kind of more organic I
like that it looks very utilitarian it
looks stripped-down it looks like it was
designed to work and that's it
it's not designed with a ton of
aesthetics in mind it's not designed to
look cool which I mean if we're gonna be
frank about it definitely Elevens
sonic screwdriver which he did wave
around a bit like a magic wand was
designed to have a certain cool factor
in the way that it looked I think 12 was
potentially designed that way as well
that one almost seriously just felt like
it was designed to look like a toy and
it made for a very good boy it's
actually one of my favorite ones that I
had as a toy as a prop in the Charlotte
looked weird though so I am eager to get
some more time with this sonic
screwdriver that looks like it was
something cobbled together that the
doctor will continue to use because it
works why should I change it or at least
that's what I hope the attitude will be
I would actually really like for the
doctor for the thirteenth doctor to have
the opportunity to upgrade its
streamline it make it look prettier make
it look more like you know high-end
technology and just shrug it off and go
see why it's fine the way it is I would
love it if she did that but even if she
does even if we don't see her flat out
do that as for as long as she keeps this
particular one it's if that's gonna be
my head cannon I
I wonder if people's issue is kind of
like the exposed sort of crystal thing
if like they feel does that is that like
too new agey is that to sort of almost
magical realism mystical whatever I
don't know I suspect that there's
probably been more than a few
SOI jokes about the thing because oh my
god that wasn't made tired the first 500
million people who made a sonic vibrator
joke when a female doctor was first
announced but I think it looks nice and
I'm really looking forward to getting my
hands on one so I like it
I like what the look implies I like what
it implies about the person who made it
I like what the look implies about the
circumstances under which it was made at
which you know we're gonna find out
about anyways and hopefully ORS makes
for a decent story in and of itself new
sonic screwdriver gets this particular
geeks seal of approval doesn't mean you
have to like it though so whatever your
thoughts are like it hate it bit torn
want to see it in action before you make
a call whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it you know the stuff that
you can do I'm not gonna list it all I
will mention patreon it's the big one
there's a link for that as well as a
bunch of other stuff that I do it's all
down below so until next time this
council is churned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]